look closely at toby mcguire's
who am i
you sure you want to know
i'm spider-man
why are you wearing a spider-man suit
why are you wearing a spider-man suit i
said i would wear a spider-man suit
today i always wear the spider-man suit
exactly it's not fair that you always
gonna wear the spider-man suit but this
guess is always about you why could you
just let me have this you're not gonna
want to see two guys
shut up miles this isn't about you
take that off you're an imposter you're
the apostle i told you i wanted to wear
this today but mine fits so much better
but i'm a bigger spider-man fan than you
you didn't send me a text message why
are you here you don't even have a suit
you're not even in this movie you better
take that off you better take that off i
want to be involved
[Music]
all right guys i guess jon gets to wear
the suit today but we got the spider-man
no way home second trailer i know i said
we have koi gendro with us today he's
actually hosting the spider-man trailer
event at the movie theater itself right
now and that's a much bigger opportunity
than being here so instead we got our
second favorite white boy aaron thanks
for being here
happy to be second place
in the white category
oh [ __ ] ever since i got bit by that
spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
wow
here we go here we go watch that spell
where you wanted everyone to forget the
peter parker spiderman
whoa
we started getting some visitors
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
i know a couple of magic words myself
starting with the word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
[Music]
you're flying out dude
oh jk what do you mean
there it is there it is confirmed
oh no
[Music]
oh
my god
the statue of liberty
oh that's the phone
[Music]
did we see him again with the hood
lizards
whoa
oh my god oh
you know what that means
yes
yes oh [ __ ]
he can't stop telling me and andrew
coming through he can stop them from
getting into this trailer what are we
doing let's watch
[Music]
this does feel a lot more dark and
dramatic the way tom holland was
describing it would be yeah a lot more
serious more emotionally heavy the
highest more consequential yeah spell
where you wanted everyone to forget the
peter parker spiderman
every universe every universe
you guys can't not have the [ __ ]
spiderman in every universe but mainly
these two universes there are parts of
this moment that look a little bit
little is not
[Music]
i'm finished what was your name again dr
otto octavius
it really stands out that he says you're
not peter parker yeah it's like he's
lost which means you have to see it's
the peter parker that he knows
i know a couple of magic words myself
glad that she points it out
it's interesting that they are involved
like in all this the high stakes magical
crap sure his friends are still
in the thick of it with him
you're flying out
wow
he's just joking
and arms versus ours so yeah we heard
about this plot i'm sorry
of the
yeah
the fact that
peter feels responsible for them because
they all die fighting spider-man yep and
he tries to steal the box
those are rumors
[Music]
so it looks like they're constructing
something around the statue of liberty
building yeah
yeah i'm hearing his voice man
[Music]
i knew rock stars are gonna have a
feeling lizard instead that's so great
literally
wow
what else is
is that like solidified sanity wow look
at all that scaffolding i haven't seen
that before
that actually feels like a lot of
dramatic after that moment heart getting
back to all the times that the toby and
andrew ones were
they're starting to come through who's
coming through can't stop him
we don't want you to stop him we know
who's coming we know who's coming over
grace
and morbius
i'm loving everything that we're seeing
there's a lot of things that we're kind
of theorized about that are definitely
coming true you know uh peter would be
wanting to when he's fighting with
strange and it becomes kind of a game of
hot potato with the cube due to the fact
that peter feels morally responsible for
the lives of these individuals all chaos
is going to eventually break loose like
structurally when you're looking at it
you start piecing some of it together it
kind of looks like doc awkward breaks
out and then they imprisoned doc ock
they started imprisoning the other
villains and then bam just kind of goes
into this crazy chaotic mess towards the
end what'd you guys think of the electro
look oh they look cool i thought it
looked a lot better than um the chasm
two electro i like that they had the
little star kind of harkening back to
other versions or more classic version
but we know him as jamie foxx looks like
himself but you know cooler yeah
well that yellow lightning combined with
the fact that whatever outfit he's got
on looks more sort of industrial and of
like a power station or something like
that the way he's charging up off of the
transformers and everything tangible but
also really powerful and sort of
enigmatic almost well it seemed like
there was one shot where he was all
blued out but then later on you could
see his jamie foxx's face with the uh
yellow electro and he's got a new suit
to complement it all doc seems like to
be the most focused villain out of them
all they're actually giving a look i
like how it seems like they are bringing
over the doc awk from spider-man 2 to
the point where he doesn't just seem
like this chewing up the scenery type of
villain it doesn't seem like they're
completely doing a rewrite on him
especially when he's looking at him
going you're not peter i guess when he
goes to fight peter on the bridge he
thinks that it's probably the toby
maguire underneath there yeah and then
when he's in prison
you're going to get a little bit more of
that like poetic talk that you kind of
get from alfred molina in spider-man 2.
um i love a lot of the dialogues being
given i wish we got a little bit more
green goblin but we got just enough we
got just enough i swear like that one
shot is so hard to make out but it looks
like they did even have him like on the
glider in something other than the
helmet like
yeah yeah it was one by really fast yeah
the costume looks like
basically the one we know from the 2002
one yes so all those rumors about him
having a modified costume seemingly from
what we see in this trailer seem to be
false but yeah i dig it i'm not mad at
the fact that it looks the same sandman
looks massive we didn't get a shot of
tan of thomas stated church we got
lizard confirmed and the stakes feel
very real like a lot of the common
complaints that i've heard and that i've
kind of shared with a couple of the tom
holland ones it seems like a lot of that
won't be as present this time around or
there's some things that seem like
they'll be a little bit undercut with
that marvel humor
sure but it's also very spider-man to
like laugh at a character's title and
name like when they hear auto octavius
and for him to be giggling at it as
serious as we took otto octavius in the
spider-man 2 sam raimi film in like the
comics and shows peter parker would
laugh at a thing like that
yeah and one thing this trailer did get
me excited about it like as much as
they're throwing the multiverse villains
at you this got me excited to see them
scooby doo this crap yeah
because dr strange like he's obviously
acknowledging like yes the spell went
wrong and you know they're gonna be at
odds when peter takes the cube but he's
also probably got a bunch of stuff to go
and take care of across the universe and
spider-man's gotta fix his mess at home
and i'm excited to see the three of them
in that journey and it seems like just
the stakes and how massive the action's
gonna be will be very harrowing probably
for mj and for uh you know uh [ __ ]
ned yeah so yeah i'm excited for them a
lot of the dr strange stuff seems like
they really cut around it so i'm i'm
curious as to what they're hiding in and
all that i will say for this trailer
definitely captures the the tonal
consistency with this peter parker of
him being involved in the situation then
his guilt or his feeling of unworthiness
kind of causing the trouble to go
further like with the last movie it was
the glasses this movie it seems like
it's going to be the cube and then he's
going to have to rectify his mistake by
owning up to his responsibility and his
power as spider-man and the lives of his
loved ones truly endanger this time
around and he has to go rescue save them
i mean that's just classic spider-man
jumping after your woman as she's
falling to her death
that version andrew garfield's gonna
slide under at the last minute yeah
actually i wouldn't be surprised if
you're right about that
yeah because the way oh that's a great
call because like how gwen fell to her
death an amazing spider-man too and then
this time he gets a chance of redemption
to save her that would be so cool i mean
okay so yeah the final fight will be
taking place in the statue of liberty
looks like they've been constructing
like we need to put the shield on top of
the statue of liberty
that's what it started looking like and
then it's slowly crumbling as they're
fighting it's crumbling away then we're
going to get our big epic finale but
this looks intense this looks harrowing
and it also looks like fun i mean this
is giving me everything i want easily
most anticipated movie now it's all
fight for tickets
for each other
all right guys what do you think about
the trailer leave your thoughts down
below uh thank you aaron for being here
john you look great guys subscribe click
the notification bell we're gonna be
talking about this quite a bit thank you
so much
you